what's heaven it's a peaceful place in
the sky
are you going to heaven no
[Applause]
[Music]
no why not
you gotta be a good person to go to
heaven
there's a go today the artificial
intelligence created to protect us
detonated a nuclear warhead in Los
Angeles
for as long as AI is a threat
we will never stop hunting companies
this is a fight for our very existence
whatever's in there they're sure worried
about someone getting in
yeah we're good now
[Music]
we're just saying we can't go to heaven
cause you're not good
and I'm not a person
did you locate the weapon yeah it's a
key
belts
we are this close to winning the war
execute her or we go extinct
[Music]
thank you
they're coming to get me